I don't know if it's the string of
particularly bad Disney sequels I had to
sit through the last few days or the
fact that this might actually be a good
movie but 101 dalmatians two patches
London Adventure is actually kind of a
good movie I dare even say on par with
the original yeah I can't believe those
words are leaving my mouth either really
this is the one it has the spirit of the
original artwork similar to the original
some great update some good callbacks
it's exciting I didn't always know where
it was going to go it's funny
adventurous oh my god I think I came
across an actual good Disney sequels it
begins not too shortly after the first
one where we see the Dalmatian
plantation is about to be put into
effect so the family is about to move
but one of the puppies named patch is
feeling a little out of place and it's
understandably so when you're the middle
child of 101 you can get a little lost
hungry for his chance to stand out he
sees that a TV dog named Thunderbolt is
holding auditions for a new dog to be on
his show what he doesn't know is this
current sidekick named little lightning
has told him that they were about to
kill off his character so he needs to
find a way to prove to the public that
he's a real hero patch gets roped in as
he knows everything about the show but
they seem to cause more chaos and misery
than they do save people from it
meanwhile karela oh god how do I even
explain this get sucked into the art
world because she sees a guy who paints
a dot she admits that it feeds her crazy
obsession and they just kind of paint
dots together but he seems to be running
out of inspiration or at least she
doesn't like the work he's putting out
so she once again tries to kidnap the
puppies only this time she's not gonna
make a coat out of him she wants to
paint the canvas with him oh my god that
is delightfully psychotic in fact I
think she's even crazier in this movie
than she was in the last one the fly
thing is as I describe this plot I
realize it's kind of a formulaic plot
well for the most part the art stuff is
perfectly out there but there's a lot of
callbacks to the original there's
another liar reveal story another kid
feeling out of place we've seen all this
stuff before
in fact this is about as typical at
Disney sequel script as you can get but
there's one thing this movie has that
those other Disney sequels didn't have
charm
it's a charming movie the characters are
so likable the comedy actually gets a
few laughs out loud laughs the pacing is
never too rushed the slow moments are
perfectly slow the fast moments are
perfectly fast the voice talent is
especially good that's Martin Short as
the artist he's really funny as hell
gorillas voice is hilarious the hero dog
is delightfully full of himself
Jason Alexander is another villain
that's a lot of fun and they got a real
kid to play the puppy not some adult
just doing a high-pitch boys like this
that's just uncomfortable and weird the
artwork is also really great these are
some very distinct backgrounds that are
very similar to the original I like the
original little better because they were
hand-painted and these are clearly
computer but by god they still look
great
it can be extreme and over-the-top but
it can also be kind of subtle and
delicate too I guess the one thing
that's missing from it is it doesn't
feel quite as big as the original I mean
the climax is another car chase and it's
just Carrillo trying to catch the
puppies again there's even our scene
where all the dogs bark to communicate
but in my opinion the film makes up for
it by having better comedy than the
first the first isn't especially funny
it's just cute this one has a much
better sense of humor and you can tell
the writing is trying much harder than
it really needs to try and I love that I
love taking this idea that really should
only entertain your two-year-old and
actually throwing in some witty dialogue
so is it a great film by no means but
you're talking to a guy who doesn't even
think the first one was a great film but
the first one what's good thank you Dan
handsome charm to it this is exactly the
same thing I love the interaction off of
these people I love that cute little pup
talking to the egotistical dog I like
that weird artist talking to the insane
gorilla deville
I like the husband and wife doing a
little counterpoint duet in the opening
it's just it's likable it's really
likable it reminds me a lot of the
Wallace and run this shorts are the
Shaun the Sheep movie it's not like
you're slapping your knee at the comedy
but there's just something inventive
about it something so delightfully
innocent yet still intelligent like
I can't act like this is any phenomenal
feat of animation or cinema storytelling
but it's just a nice enjoyable little
movie a movie that couldn't predict
where it was gonna go a movie the head a
line or two I might actually quote out
of context a movie I legitimately want
to stay and watch until the very end if
somebody turned it off I would go rent
it and watch the rest of it I know
that's how movies are supposed to work
but for a lot of Disney sequels that's
not what happens it's a perfectly
entertaining little film and after all
the stinkers I've had to watch
entertaining little film to me equals
amazing
[Music]
you